thank you sir hey appreciate you man I  see you in a bit  what are you doing so you're just going  to leave your car yeah he takes care of  it for me not to worry about it all  right I got this guy's motor and then we  need you up there okay appreciate it man  go go  yep so great good to see you yeah  somehow you don't walk side by big  enough yeah preciate it  so is that what you do yeah  hey guys go  yeah every time you - every time and  therefore the proposal not read right on  me all right man  no to work  something is done  by going on  Oh  are you looking over summer so yes  almost at time  right  No  I got  yeah two bucks Greg Rogers right over  there how's it going good hey Tony you  said it's a walk right up front let me  know if you need anything  yes sir many guys been sitting here for  a while I'll get right with you all  right take your time no and here he is  the man of the hour  Greg Rogers the newest member of the  UCLA Bruin  you